This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档I-Heart播客。保证真人。嗨，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉不够安全的坦诚对话，但你可以和一个懂得他在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听“艰难学习”节目，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在IHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理坚韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Thanks for joining in again and for listening to this episode. Today we're going to talk about love languages. Maybe you've heard of them. Maybe you haven't. Maybe that's why you decided to listen to this episode.
在IHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。欢迎回到“你二十岁的心理学”（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的重大变化和转变以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。感谢你再次收听并收听本期节目。今天我们要聊聊爱的语言。也许你听说过。也许你没有。也许这就是你决定收听这期节目的原因。
But regardless of your pre-existing knowledge of the idea, there is plenty to learn today. If there is noise in the background, I'm so sorry. I'm currently recording this under a blanket in my house because it's raining. Because Lenina does not sleep. She just doesn't. So love languages. That's what we're talking about this week. Essentially, there are ways that people express and receive.
但无论你对这个概念先前了解多少，今天都有很多东西要学。如果背景有噪音，我真的很抱歉。我目前正在我屋里的毯子底下录音，因为外面在下雨。因为莱妮娜（Lenina）不睡觉。她就是不睡。所以爱的语言。这就是我们本周要谈论的内容。本质上，这是人们表达和接受的方式。
love. That's the basic premises. And the founder of this concept, essentially he believes, his name's Chapman, and he believes that he's created a tool, a test, or I guess kind of like a dimensional method, that can reveal exactly how you want to be loved and the ways in which you best show love. And since its creation back in like the late 80s, early 90s, it's expanded quite significantly. Obviously, it's now an online quiz that I'm sure I would say most of you have done. And it's no longer just primarily used for couples. It's used for friendships, the relationships you have with your family, and even get this in the workplace. Although I'm not quite sure how they incorporate physical touch into that. That sounds like.
爱。这就是基本前提。这个概念的创始人，本质上他相信，他的名字叫查普曼（Chapman），他相信他创造了一个工具、一个测试，或者我猜有点像一种维度方法，可以确切地揭示你希望如何被爱以及你最好地表达爱的方式。自从它在80年代末90年代初创立以来，它已经有了相当显着的扩展。显然，它现在是一个在线测试，我敢说你们大多数人都做过。它不再主要用于情侣。它被用于友谊、你与家人的关系，甚至你懂的，在职场中。虽然我不太确定他们是如何将身体接触融入其中的。听起来就像。
They're walking a very thin line between healthy work relationships and a lawsuit. But anyhow, you can kind of get the gist. It has become its own kind of phenomenon and a pretty core part of our psychobabble. I remember when I was at uni, this was like a huge thing that people talked about, oh, you know, like, what's your love language? I remember doing the quiz. I've probably done it quite a few times and it's changed every time, but I remember doing it with a group of friends like at one of my uni dining tables, like way back in 2017. And even today, people often, you know, trot out their self-identified love languages as kind of a shorthand to indicate how they behave in relationships in the same kind of casual and convenient where you might talk about your star sign or
他们踩在健康工作关系和诉讼之间的模糊界线上。但无论如何，你大概能明白。它已经成为了一种现象，并且成为了我们心理唠叨的核心部分。我记得我上大学的时候，这是一个巨大的热门话题，人们会讨论，哦，你知道的，比如，你的爱的语言是什么？我记得做过这个测试。我可能做过好几次，而且每次结果都不一样，但我记得早在2017年的时候，我和一群朋友在大学的一个餐桌上做过这个测试。甚至在今天，人们也经常，你知道的，搬出他们自己认定的爱的语言，作为一种简写，来表明他们在亲密关系中的行为，就像你可能随便而方便地谈论你的星座，
your Myers-Briggs type or your Hogwarts house. I see it on hinge profiles all the time, like all the time, you know, I think it's even a prompt on hinge. And funnily enough, like the dating app actually did some psychological research on love languages that we're going to talk about later. And, you know, it's in every context. I've talked about it with, I think, every single partner that I've ever had, even if I wasn't the one who brought it up, it's just become such a quintessential part of beginning a relationship or continuing a relationship is this discussion around what's your love language, how do you want me to show love? Now, acknowledging that it has become such a huge part of relationship jargon these days, is it even real? Our love language is real. Is there any science
或者你的迈尔斯-布里格斯类型（Myers-Briggs），或者你的霍格沃茨学院。我在Hinge交友软件的个人资料里经常看到，真的经常，你知道的，我认为它甚至是Hinge上的一个提示。有趣的是，这个约会软件实际上对爱的语言做了一些心理学研究，我们稍后会讨论。而且，你知道的，它出现在每个语境中。我想我和我谈过的每一个伴侣都谈论过它，即使不是我先提起的，它也已经成为了开始一段关系或维持一段关系不可或缺的一部分，这就是关于你的爱的语言是什么、你希望我如何表达爱的讨论。现在，承认它已经成为关系术语中如此重要的一部分，它真的是真的吗？爱的语言是真的吗？这里面有任何科学依据吗？
to it at all? Or is it just this weird murky pseudoscience slash like buzzfeed? quiz. I think there is a huge trend these days with a lot of these, like, personality quizzes and judgments that attempt to tell you things about yourself. And there's really no kind of indicator of whether they're accurate, but we put a lot of merit in them at times. So how much method is there to the madness of the five love language quiz? Can you truly believe it? If you go into your relationship, having done the quiz, knowing what you know about yourself, is it actually going to make you happier. So we're going to unpack all of that and more in this episode. So stay tuned. So if you're one of the few people who hasn't heard of love languages, here's a simple rundown.
还是这只是一种奇怪的、模棱两可的伪科学加Buzzfeed风格的小测验？我认为现在有这样一种巨大的趋势，很多这样的性格测验和判断都试图告诉你关于你自己的事情。真的没有什么指标能证明它们是否准确，但有时我们对它们寄予厚望。那么，这五个爱的语言测试的疯狂背後有多少方法论呢？你真的能相信它吗？如果你带着做过测试、对自己有所了解的心态进入恋爱关系，它真的会让你更快乐吗？所以我们将在本期节目中剖析所有这些以及更多内容。所以请收听。所以如果你是少数几个没听说过爱的语言的人之一，这里有一个简单的概述。
So the five love languages are these different ways of expressing and receiving love. They are words of affirmation, quality time, receiving gifts, acts of service and physical touch. The premise is this. Not everyone, communicates love in the same way and likewise people have different ways that they prefer to receive love and the concept of love languages it was developed by this man his name was gary chapman and he wrote a book about it his book was the five love languages the secret to love that loss and in this book which has become quite famous he describes these five unique styles of communicating love categories that he's kind of distilled from his experience as a marriage counsellor.
所以这五种爱的语言是表达和接受爱的不同方式。它们是肯定的言词（words of affirmation）、精心时刻（quality time）、接受礼物（receiving gifts）、服务行动（acts of service）和身体接触（physical touch）。其前提是这样的。并非每个人，都以同样的方式传达爱，同样地，人们也有不同的偏好来接受爱，爱的语言这个概念是由这个人开发的，他的名字叫加里·查普曼（gary chapman），他写了一本关于它的书，他的书是《爱的五种语言：如何表达内心深处的真挚爱意》（The Five Love Languages: The Secret to Love that Lasts），在这本变得相当著名的书中，他描述了这五种独特的表达爱的风格，这些类别是他从自己作为婚姻顾问的经验中提炼出来的。
Bit of background on Gary Chapman. He's actually incredibly well known in social psychology. He runs an institute in the United States, and they do heaps of pretty groundbreaking work or just interesting work on relationships and communication styles. And he kind of a side note, but he did this amazing experiment, I think 10 years ago, where he was able to predict out of 100 couples, which, ones would last and which ones would with like a 95% accuracy, all based on how they communicate, their communication styles, which is kind of different to the five love languages, but it was incorporated
关于加里·查普曼的一些背景。他在社会心理学界其实非常知名。他在美国运营着一个研究所，他们在关系和沟通风格方面做了大量具有开创性的工作或仅仅是有趣的工作。顺便说一句，他大约在10年前做过一个惊人的实验，他能够从100对情侣中预测出哪些会持久，哪些不会，准确率高达95%，全都是基于他们的沟通方式，他们的沟通风格，这与爱的语言有点不同，但它有时被整合进去了。
at times. So what he says is that we probably all relate to these love languages. Everyone loves receiving gifts. Everyone loves words of affirmation at different times. But there's definitely one that will speak to you the most. And discovering you and your partner's primary love language and speaking that language regularly may help create a better understanding of each other's needs and kind of support each other's growth in your relationship, whatever the parameters of that may be. So here's a bit of a deeper overview of what each of them is, acknowledging before we dive in that not one single love language is better than another, nor are we kind of just limited to one way of expressing love to others. You can feel an attachment to all of these. If you're listening to them or
所以他说的是，我们可能都与这些爱的语言有关。每个人都喜欢收礼物。每个人在不同时刻都喜欢肯定的言词。但绝对有一种是最能触动你的。发现你和伴侣的主要爱的语言并定期说这种语言，可能有助于更好地理解彼此的需求，并在你们的关系中支持彼此的成长，无论关系的参数可能是什么。所以这里有一个更深入的概述，关于它们各自是什么，在我们深入探讨之前，我们要承认，没有哪一种单一的爱的语言比另一种更好，我们也不仅限于向他人表达爱的唯一方式。你可以对所有这些都感到依恋。如果你是第一次听到它们或
hearing about them for the first time and you're like, well, I don't really think one of them represents me. That's kind of the whole point. Everyone likes each of these, probably a little bit. It's just about which one kind of stands out. So first, we have words of affirmation. So people with words of affirmation as a love language, they value verbal acknowledgement of affection. You know, they like when you frequently tell them, I love you. They're like compliments, words of appreciation and verbal encouragement. And in the modern age, These people often probably really enjoy frequent digital communication, like texting and social media engagement and written and spoken, you know, efforts of affection matter the most to these people,
第一次听说它们，然后你觉得，嗯，我真的不觉得其中哪一个代表我。这正是重点所在。每个人都可能有点喜欢其中的每一项。这只是关于哪一个更突出。首先，我们有肯定的言词（words of affirmation）。所以以肯定的言词作为爱的语言的人，他们重视对affection（爱意）的言语认可。你知道的，他们喜欢你经常对他们说，我爱你。他们喜欢赞美、感激的话语和言语鼓励。而在现代，这些人可能非常喜欢频繁的数字通信，比如发短信和社交媒体互动，书面和口头上的，你知道的，表达爱意的努力对这些人来说最重要，
above other things. You would rather receive a heartfelt message or a compliment from someone you love than maybe a gift or a hug. So the second one is quality time. So people whose love language is quality time, they feel the most adored when their partner actively wants to spend time with them and it's kind of always down to like hang out or do things. They particularly love when their partner or the person they're with is actively listening, making eye contact and their full presence is kind of in that moment.
高于其他一切。比起礼物或拥抱，你可能更愿意收到你爱的人发来的真诚信息或赞美。所以第二种是精心时刻（quality time）。所以爱的语言是精心时刻的人，当他们的伴侣积极地想要花时间陪伴他们并且总是随时准备一起出去玩或做事情时，他们会感到最被宠爱。他们特别喜欢当他们的伴侣或和他们在一起的人在积极倾听、进行眼神交流并且全身心地投入到那个时刻。
They like date nights. They like doing things together. This love language, it's all about giving your undivided attention to that kind of special person without the distraction of your phone or another. kind of stimuli or something else in the background, no interference. And these people, they have a strong desire to actively spend time with their significant other, have those meaningful conversations and, you know, share in hobbies and activities. Next up, acts of service. Kind of, like all of them, the title, you can kind of gather a lot from that. But if your love
他们喜欢约会之夜。他们喜欢一起做事。这种爱的语言，全都是关于把你的全神贯注给予那个特别的人，而不受手机或其他刺激物或背景中其他东西的分心，没有任何干扰。这些人有强烈的愿望去积极地陪伴他们的另一半，进行那些有意义的对话，并且，你知道的，分享爱好和活动。接下来，服务行动（acts of service）。有点像，像所有这些一样，标题，你可以从中收集到很多信息。但如果你的爱的语言
language is acts of service, you really value when your partner goes out of their way to make your life easier. It's things like, I don't know, bringing you like Panadol when you're sick, making you coffee in the morning, picking up your dry cleaning, making the bed for you when you've had a busy day at work, doing the laundry, simple acts that would maybe take time out of your day and they decide to kind of take it on for you. So this love language is for people who believe that, I guess, actions speak louder than words. Unlike those who prefer to hear about how much they're cared for as with words of affirmation, people who fit into the acts of service category, they like to be shown that they're appreciated. Doing the small or bigger chores to make their lives easier or
是服务行动，当你的伴侣不辞劳苦让你的生活更轻松时，你真的会很感激。这是诸如，我不知道，在你生病时给你带必理痛（Panadol）、早上为你煮咖啡、去取干洗的衣服、在你工作忙碌了一天后为你铺床、洗衣服等事情，这些简单的行动可能会占用你的一天中的时间，而他们决定为你承担下来。所以这种爱的语言是为那些认为，我猜，行动胜于雄辩的人准备的。与那些喜欢听到别人有多在乎他们的人（就像肯定的言词一样）不同，适合服务行动类别的人喜欢看到他们受到赞赏。做一些小杂务或大杂务来让他们的生活更轻松或
more comfortable is, you know, pretty highly cherished by these people. Okay, gifts. Perhaps the most controversial. I want to say, don't mistake this love language for materialism. The receiver of the gifts, it's not that you spent money. It's that there's thoughtfulness and effort behind the gift. And it's pretty straightforward. You feel loved when people give you visual symbols of love, as Chapman calls it. It's not about the monetary value, like I said. It's not about receiving diamonds or a car, but it's the symbolic thought behind the gift. And people with this style recognize and value the gift giving process, the careful reflection, you know, deliberately choosing an object that represents the relationship and kind of the emotional benefits from receiving the present. So people
更舒适，你知道的，被这些人高度珍视。好吧，礼物。也许最具争议的。我想说，不要把这种爱的语言误解为物质主义。礼物的接受者，不是因为你花了钱。而是礼物背后的深思熟虑和努力。这很简单。当人们给你查普曼所说的爱的视觉象征时，你会感到被爱。正如我所说，这与货币价值无关。这不是关于收到钻石或汽车，而是礼物背后的象征性思考。具有这种风格的人认可并重视送礼的过程，仔细的深思熟虑，你知道的，刻意选择一个代表关系的物品，以及从收到礼物中获得的的情感益处。所以爱的语言是接受礼物的人，
whose love language is receiving gifts, they enjoy being gifted something that is both physical but also meaningful. And for me, gift giving is the love language I like to show. I don't so much like receiving gifts, but for me, like if I love someone, it's kind of, it's really meaningful to give them something that shows that in like a physical form. So finally, the fifth love language is physical touch. So people with physical touch as their love language, they feel loved when they receive physical signs of affection like kissing, holding hands, cuddling on the couch and of course, sex. Physical intimacy and touch can be incredibly affirming and they really serve as quite a powerful, emotional, soulful connector for people with this love language. And there's this theory,
他们喜欢收到既有形又有意义的礼物。对我来说，送礼是我喜欢展示的爱的语言。我不太喜欢收礼物，但对我来说，如果我爱一个人，把它变成一种有形的形式来向他们展示那是很有意义的。所以最后，第五种爱的语言是身体接触。所以以身体接触为爱的语言的人，当他们得到亲吻、手拉手、在沙发上依偎当然还有性等身体上的爱意表示时，会感到被爱。身体亲密和接触可以具有令人难以置信的肯定作用，它们确实可以作为这种爱的语言的人的一个强大、情感上、灵魂深处的连接器。有这样一个理论，
give it as much thought as you want, as much weight as you want, but there's a theory that the roots of physical touch go back to childhood. Some people only felt a deep connection and love, by their parents when they were held, kissed and touched. And in adulthood, that might manifest in physical touch being their primary love language. People who communicate their appreciation through this language, when they consent to it, feel appreciated when you hold them, when you cuddle them, when you love them through warmth and comfort and physical touch. So these are all pretty typical forms of expressing love.
你愿意赋予它多少思考、多少分量都可以，但有一个理论认为，身体接触的根源可以追溯到童年。有些人只有在被拥抱、亲吻和抚摸时，才会感受到父母给予的深厚联系和爱。而在成年期，这可能会表现为身体接触是他们主要的爱的语言。通过这种语言传达感激之情的人，在他们同意的情况下，当你拥抱他们、当你依偎他们、当你用温暖、舒适和身体接触来爱他们时，会感到被感激。所以这些都是表达爱的非常典型的形式，
I think we're all fairly familiar with them, and I'm sure we've all experienced them, I'm hoping. There aren't really any surprises here, though I'm sure you can maybe see perhaps some love languages that may be missing, but one of them that I talked about with someone once was like cooking for someone. It's not so much like the act of service, and it's not gift giving, it's something in between. And we're going to get further into this later for sure, because that's a big argument against the use of the love language, queer or distinction.
我想我们都相当熟悉它们，而且我确信我们都经历过，我希望如此。这里没有什么真正的惊喜，尽管我确信你也许能看出可能缺少的某些爱的语言，但我曾经和某人谈论过其中的一个，比如为某人做饭。这不太像是服务行动，也不是送礼，它是介于两者之间的事情。我们稍后一定会更深入地探讨这一点，因为这是反对使用爱的语言、特质或区别的一个大论点。
It's that it doesn't really capture everyone. And love is a lot more nuanced than kind of a five, point categorical scale. But before we kind of dig into the controversy, I want to discuss the quiz that is most typically used to discover your love language. So the creator, Chapman, we've mentioned about, talked about him. He developed this kind of test based on his interactions with thousands, and I mean thousands of couples in one-on-one therapy sessions and interviews. There's a TV series about this if you want to know more, essentially. But through this experience with his clients, I'm just going to note here the majority of them were heterosexual and monogamous,
那就是它并没有真正涵盖所有人。而且爱比五分制的分类量表要微妙得多。但在我们深入探讨争议之前，我想讨论一下最常用于发现你的爱的语言的测试。所以创作者查普曼，我们提到过他，谈论过他。他开发这种测试是基于他与成千上万、我的意思是成千上万的情侣在一对一治疗课程和访谈中的互动。如果你想了解更多，基本上有一个关于此的电视节目。但通过他与客户的这段经历，我要在这里指出，他们大多数是异性恋和一夫一妻制的，
but through his experiences talking with them, he determined that not only are there five very distinct ways of showing and receiving love, but we can clinically discern which one suits a person best by asking them to rate some fairly simple statements and just to say which they would prefer. So for example, one of the questions or statements might begin with this. So it's more meaningful when A, I receive a loving note from my loved one, or B, my partner and I hug. So with the first option, that obviously represents words of affirmation and the second being physical touch. This goes on for a while. I don't know how many there are, I'm guessing probably over 20. And at the end, you get a percentage for each of the five languages that tells you
但通过他与他们交谈的经验，他确定，不仅有五种非常独特的方式来表达和接受爱，而且我们可以通过要求他们对一些相当简单的陈述进行评分并说出他们更喜欢哪一个，来临床辨别哪一种最适合一个人。所以例如，其中一个问题或陈述可能是这样开始的。所以更有意义的是，A，我收到我爱的人的一张充满爱意的便条，或者B，我和我的伴侣拥抱。所以对于第一个选项，这显然代表了肯定的言词，第二个则是身体接触。这种情况持续了一段时间。我不知道有多少个，我猜大概超过20个。最后，你对五种语言中的每一种都有一个百分比，它告诉你
which you would like to receive and the percentages add up to 100, meaning there's room for all of them in your final result. It's very rare that you'll get 100% just for one. Actually, it's impossible. It's not rare. It's impossible. You're definitely going to perhaps have two or three that really are quite significant. And sometimes they're pretty close.
你想要接受哪种，这些百分比加起来是100，这意味着你的最终结果中为所有这些都留出了空间。你很少会仅仅因为其中一种而得到100%。事实上，这是不可能的。这并不罕见。这是不可能的。你肯定会有两三个真正相当显着的。有时它们非常接近。
So, for example, for me, my lowest love languages are quality time and words of affirmation. and they're both around 12%. If you haven't done it before, take five minutes now, pause the podcast, I promise I'm not saying anything that interesting, and complete the quiz. Just Google five love languages. It's free. It's completely free. And answer intuitively.
所以，例如，对，我来说，我最低的爱的语言是精心时刻和肯定的言词。它们都在12%左右。如果你以前没做过，现在花五分钟，暂停播客，我保证我没有说任何那么有趣的事情，然后完成这个测试。只需在谷歌上搜索“五种爱的语言”。它是免费的。它是完全免费的。并凭直觉回答。
Don't think too much into it. That's how you'll get the most authentic answer. But hold off reading too much into it right away. Wait till the end of the episode, then consider how much weight you want to give this. What's the merit you'd like to give this tool? A big question I kind of always wondered, maybe you're wondering it as well, is what is the most common love language? The founder of the quiz, he analyzed the results of, I think, over 10,000 people who took the quiz in 2010. And he found that words of affirmation was the most popular
不要想太多。这就是你如何得到最真实的答案。但暂时不要过度解读。等到本期节目结束，然后再考虑你想赋予这个多大的分量。你想赋予这个工具什么价值？我一直想知道的一个大问题，也许你也在纳闷，最常见的爱的语言是什么？该测试的创始人分析了2010年参加测试的超过10,000人的结果。他发现肯定的言词是最受欢迎的
language, but by really thin margin. And in 2018, the dating app hinge, yes, that's right, Hinge, analyzed the app and found the most covered love language was quality time by far. So there's been the shift in the last eight years between 2010 and 2018. Chapman found it was words of affirmation and then when Hinge did it, quality time, I think it was like 200% higher than the second option, which was actually words of affirmation, but by a long shot. And when I read this, I kind of found it equally parts funny and a little bit sad because these are my lowest by far, but also it's not something you can really change, and it's still
语言，但优势微乎其微。而在2018年，约会软件Hinge，是的，没错，Hinge，对该应用进行了分析，发现最受欢迎的爱的语言一直是精心时刻，遥遥领先。所以在过去八年里，即2010年到2018年之间，发生了这种转变。查普曼发现它是肯定的言词，然后当Hinge做这项调查时，是精心时刻，我想它比第二名高出200%左右，第二名实际上是肯定的言词，但差距很大。当我读到这个时，我发现它既搞笑又有点悲伤，因为这些远远是我的最低项，但这也是你无法真正改变的事情，而且你仍然
possible to access those areas of expressing love, even if they are the most prominent. Or not the most prominent. Sorry, even if they're not the most prominent. Yeah, there we go. So diving further into this data collected by Hinge, because I find this really fascinating, like a dating app doing psychological research, but they also assessed like the differences in love languages between men and women using the app. So whilst quality time was the most common love language overall, there was some discrepancies between men and women and how they looked at the other love languages. So for men, have a guess, which is the second most important. It was physical touch. But for women, it was words of affirmation, and that was pretty comfortably ahead, the third option.
有可能接触到那些表达爱的领域，即使它们不是最突出的。或者不是最突出的。抱歉，即使它们不是最突出的。是的，就是这样。因此，进一步深入研究Hinge收集的这些数据，因为我觉得这真的很迷人，就像一个约会软件在做心理学研究一样，但他们还评估了使用该应用的男性和女性之间爱的语言的差异。因此，虽然精心时刻总体上是最常见的爱的语言，但男性和女性在看待其他爱的语言时存在一些差异。对于男性来说，猜猜看，第二重要的是什么？是身体接触。但对于女性来说，它是肯定的言词，而且它以相当舒适的优势领先于第三个选项。
another thing they found which I'm really not quite sure what to read into this like I read it and I tried to like find an explanation as to why this might be the case but it's just probably a coincidence but women who answered that acts of service was their love language of choice received seven times more likes than other women when you when you like held everything else constant really random and it wasn't like they were putting this in their bio it's like they used the app for a couple of months and then they were asked to take the love language quiz. And that's like, I'm just going to repeat that again. Women who answered acts of service for their love language of choice seven times more likes
他们发现的另一件事，我真的不太清楚该如何解读这一点——就像我读了它，我试图找到一个解释为什么会这样，但它可能只是巧合——回答服务行动是她们首选爱的语言的女性，与其他女性相比，获得了多七倍的点赞，当你把所有其他条件保持不变时。真的很随机，而且她们并没有把这个写在个人简介里，就像她们使用这个应用几个月，然后被要求做爱的语言测试一样。我只想再重复一遍。回答服务行动作为她们首选爱的语言的女性获得了比其他女性多七倍的点赞。
than other women. But I also personally think it depends a lot on, you know, gender, culture, customs, values. So certain love languages, which are pretty prevalent in the West, might be less common in non-Western cultures. So for example, in South Asian cultures, directly praising someone is very uncomfortable and might not be well received. Instead, I read this article, and it said that praising that person to a third party is more highly valuable when they hear about what you said about them through the great fine or through another person. Also, public displays of affection between romantic partners.
但我也个人认为这在很大程度上取决于，你知道的，性别、文化、习俗、价值观。因此，在西方相当普遍的某些爱的语言，在非西方文化中可能不太常见。例如，在南亚文化中，直接赞美某人是非常不舒服的，可能不会受到很好的欢迎。相反，我读过一篇文章，上面说，通过小道消息或另一个人听到你对他们的评价时，向第三方赞美那个人更有价值。此外，浪漫伴侣之间的公开秀恩爱行为。
It might also be less accepted, whereas in Western cultures, that kind of level of PDA, it's much more accepted. I'm not really sure why I'm not going to read too much into it, but it's just some findings and some kind of observations. and people have had. But love language, they aren't just reserved for your romantic relationships. They can also be really important in other close loving relationships we have with our friends and our family. It can be really difficult and frustrating when we don't feel understood, regardless of the context. And that's the gap that love languages help bridge by understanding how we feel seen and appreciated. And when we're able to accurately communicate that, we reduce the friction that comes when we don't feel understood by those who are closest to us.
这也可能不太被接受，而在西方文化中，那种程度的PDA（公开秀恩爱）要被接受得多。我真的不确定为什么，我不会过度解读它，但这只是一些发现和一些观察。人们也有过这样的经历。但是爱的语言，并不仅限于你的恋爱关系。它们在我们与朋友和家人的其他密切的充满爱的关系中也非常重要。当我们感觉不被理解时，无论在什么语境下，都会感到非常困难和沮丧。这就是爱的语言帮助弥合的差距，通过了解我们如何感到被看见和被赞赏。当我们能够准确地传达这一点时，我们就减少了当我们与最亲近的人感觉不被理解时产生的摩擦。
However, as popular as the concept is, many, many people have since pointed out some problems with Chapman's idea of just five love languages. Some people can maybe use this quiz, this theory, as a sort of personality test, despite the fact that the founder, his whole point is that we're supposed to adapt ourselves to our partner's love language, not demand that they use ours. And when partners use the concept of love languages only as a way to talk about how they themselves instinctively express affection or what makes them personally feel loved, Chapman noted the idea can actually actively cause trouble in relationships. There's also this idea of, you know, people are very different. There's some people who are survivors of combat or
然而，尽管这个概念很受欢迎，但许多许多人此后指出了查普曼关于仅仅五种爱的语言的想法的一些问题。有些人可能会把这个测试、这个理论当作某种性格测试来使用，尽管创始人的核心观点是我们应该调整自己去适应伴侣爱的语言，而不是要求他们使用我们的。当伴侣仅仅将爱的语言的概念作为一种方式来谈论他们自己本能地表达爱意的方式或什么让他们个人感到被爱时，查普曼指出，这个想法实际上会在关系中积极地引起麻烦。这里还有这样一个想法，你知道的，人与人是非常不同的。有些人是战斗幸存者，或者
sexual abuse trauma or people with autism spectrum disorders, for example. They're not going to respond well to partners who just insist on physical touch as that's probably not what they want to do. And that's like kind of what Chapman was saying this whole time. It's not about demanding your love language. It's about adapting to the other persons. So do our love languages have to align for a relationship to be successful or long term? Well, that's the question that's been asked quite a lot as well. And recent research revealed that couple of
性虐待创伤患者或自闭症谱系障碍患者，例如。他们不会对坚持身体接触的伴侣做出良好的反应，因为这可能不是他们想要的。这有点像查普曼一直在说的话。这不是关于要求你的爱的语言。这是关于适应另一个人的爱的语言。那么，为了让关系成功或长久，我们的爱的语言必须一致吗？嗯，这也是经常被问到的问题。最近的研究表明，那些
who share the same love languages or their love languages are aligned and they're on the same wavelength, it doesn't exactly mean that they're going to have a more successful and happy relationship. It's not like the big secret here. It's not the antidote. It's just a component. Couples who shared the same love language, they just, they weren't happier than couples who are differing styles. And that kind of suggests that mastering fluency over the love language system and adapting it based on what your partner needs in the moment is a lot more valuable than. solely relying on a dominant love language type, which is what people who share the same love language would be doing. I think that kind of promotes codependency and it prevents partners from
分享相同的爱的语言，或者他们的爱的语言是一致的并且处于同一频率的情侣，并不一定意味着他们会拥有更成功、更快乐的关系。这不像是这里的巨大秘密。它不是解药。它只是一个组成部分。拥有相同爱的语言的情侣，他们只是，并不比风格不同的情侣更快乐。这某种程度上表明，掌握爱的语言系统的流利度并根据伴侣当下需要的东西进行调整，要比
developing autonomy and authenticity and, you know, a relationship is a place for transformation and growth. And when we limit each other with a specific love language, we don't really allow room for change. And then if you also think about this, there might be times when you're just really busy and if your partner's love language and your love language is acts of service and they're also busy the whole thing kind of falls apart because neither of you can show love in that typical way the broad concepts when we lean on its practical simplicity can also feel think a little bit too simplistic since it is not completely inclusive of sexuality and culture trauma and intergenerational differences in many nuanced multicultural communities there needs to be an understanding and
仅仅依赖单一的主导爱的语言类型更有价值，而这正是分享相同爱的语言的人会做的事情。我认为这在一定程度上助长了共依存（codependency），它阻止了伴侣发展自主性和真实性，而且，你知道的，亲密关系是一个转变和成长的场所。当我们用特定的爱的语言限制彼此的时候，我们并没有真正为改变留出空间。如果你也考虑到这一点，有时你可能真的很忙，如果你的伴侣的爱的语言和你的爱的语言都是服务行动，而且他们也很忙，整件事情就会崩溃，因为你们俩都无法以那种典型的方式表达爱。当我们依赖其务实的简单性时，广泛的概念有时也会感觉
understanding that human relationships are a pretty complicated reflection of a lot of things, of childhood wounds, of attachment, of things that have happened in the past. And I think it's only when you really are able to overcome that and kind of heal those wounds of past relationships and family and develop a healthy attachment style that love languages can become something that's prominent in how you treat others. And it might even be the case that your love language really significantly changes. Here's the other issue that we've mentioned. Here's the other issue that we've mentioned, but I want to expand on it a bit further. It's this narrow idea that there are only five love languages when there has been an abundance of further research that's shown
过于简单化，因为它并未完全包容性取向和文化、创伤以及跨代差异。在许多微妙的多元文化社区中，需要有一种理解，即人类关系是许多事物的相当复杂的反映，包括童年创伤、依恋风格、过去发生的事情。我认为，只有当你真正能够克服这一点并治愈过去关系和家庭的创伤并发展出健康的依恋风格时，爱的语言才能成为你对待他人方式中突出的东西。甚至有可能是你的爱的语言发生了显着的变化。这里还有我们已经提到过的另一个问题，这里还有我们已经提到过的另一个问题，但我想对此作进一步阐述。这是一个狭隘的想法，即只有五种爱的语言，而有大量进一步的研究表明
there are so many more. And these will all vary slightly, like we said, with different cultures and demographics. So one researcher in particular, she set out to modify the love languages that were initially created or listed by Chapman. This is what she had to say. So she saw from the data that as gender norms in particular have changed, the expectations we have for our romantic relationships have become very different from the late 80s. For heterosexual couples in particular, the division of labour across gender lines is no longer kind of neatly circumscribed, leading to kind of an expansion of what we expect from our partners. Let's dive into this further. So as an example, in Chapman's book, he consistently frames kind of a man doing housework
还有更多。正如我们所说，随着不同的文化和人口统计数据，所有这些都会略有不同。所以特别是一位研究人员，她着手修改最初由查普曼创建或列出的爱的语言。这就是她不得不说的。所以她从数据中看到，特别是随着性别规范的改变，我们对恋爱关系的的期望与80年代末已经大不相同。特别是对于异性恋伴侣来说，按性别划分的劳动分工不再是那种整齐划一的界限，导致我们对伴侣的期望有所扩大。让我们对此进行更深入的探讨。作为一个例子，在查普曼的书里，他一直把男人做家务
as helping his wife out. He kind of suggests that that is an act of service. Doing an equal part of housework is an active service. Not to mention there is multiple anecdotes in his book from husbands who have, you know, succeeded in, they bring around a paycheck, they do the dishes and they're baffled when their partners want them to do more. While these attitudes, you know, of this gendered division of labor and financial means aren't totally behind us, I think the era when, you know, this is the error, I guess, when most women earn as much or sometimes more than their male partners. And most couples expect to bring more of themselves to a partnership. And also, there is no longer this traditional like idea that women do the housework men bring home the money
框定为是在帮他妻子的忙。他有点暗示那是一种服务行动。做等量的家务是一项服务行动。更不用说他的书里有很多来自丈夫们的轶事，他们成功了，他们拿回一份薪水，他们洗碗，而当他们的伴侣希望他们做更多事情时，他们感到大惑不解。虽然这些关于性别劳动分工和经济手段的态度并没有完全抛在脑后，但我认为那个时代，你知道的，这就是那个时代，我想大多数女性赚得和她们的男性伴侣一样多，或者有时甚至更多。大多数情侣都希望为伙伴关系贡献更多自己。而且不再有那种传统的观念，即女性做家务、男性带回金钱，
and when men do the housework it's an act of service it's just expected now if a man was like to me oh i did the dishes and you know that's how i showed my love for you i'd be like no that's just we both ate the same meal like of course you're going to do the fucking dishes if i cook and it's just splitting labor evenly it's not love so because of this woman's kind of observations she's created a new set of love languages. There's not five, there's seven this time. Here's what they are. So the first is activity.
当男性做家务时，这是一项服务行动，现在这只是意料之中的事。如果一个男人对我说，哦，我洗了碗，你知道的，这就是我向你表达爱的方式，我会说，不，这只是我们吃了同一顿饭，当然你会去洗该死的碗，如果我做饭的话，这只是平均分配劳动，这不是爱。因此，由于这位女性的某种观察，她创造了一套新的爱的语言。这次不是五种，而是七种。以下是它们的内容。所以第一种是活动。
So these people feel special and valued when their partner actually takes an interest in their hobbies and their activities. Even more so, those who resonate most with the activity love language, they feel especially valued when their partner makes an effort to enjoy these hobbies and interest with them. You know, like I always found it so meaningful with friends, because as we've said, it's not just romantic partners. But when my friends join me in doing something that I really love, like when they come on the podcast or when we like go to an art class together,
所以当伴侣真正对他们的爱好和活动产生兴趣时，这些人会感到很特别和受重视。更不用说，那些最能与活动类的爱的语言产生共鸣的人，当他们的伴侣努力与他们一起享受这些爱好和兴趣时，会感到格外受重视。你知道的，就像我一直觉得和朋友在一起很有意义，因为正如我们所说，这不仅限于浪漫伴侣。但是当我的朋友加入我做一些我真的很喜欢的事情时，比如当他们来上播客或者我们一起去上艺术课时，
we go for a hike, it's just so meaningful to me. The second is appreciation. So people who feel the appreciation love language applies to most to them will feel really loved and adored when their partner showers them in compliments, in praises and appreciation, when they're told I love you. This is pretty similar. to words of affirmation. These people, they like being told explicitly that they're admired and loved, and this makes them feel really understood. Here's the next one. We're two down, five to go. Emotional.
我们去远足，对我来说意义重大。第二种是赞赏。所以觉得赞赏类的爱的语言最适用于他们的人，当他们的伴侣用赞美、表扬和赞赏来对他们倾注爱意，当他们听到“我爱你”时，会感到非常被爱和被宠爱。这非常相似。对肯定的言词。这些人，他们喜欢被明确告知他们受到钦佩和喜爱，这让他们感到真正被理解。这是下一个。我们已经完成了两个，还有五个要去。情感。
Emotional love language will resonate with many of those who feel as though they can connect with their partner and be supported even in the toughest of times. Partners who are present during the worst and best moments will feel really valued by someone with an emotional love language. Financial. This is the first one that's quite different from Chapman's original love languages. And it's kind of been adapted because of, you know, what we saw now is that shift in earnings, that shift in labour. So a person who feels loved when they have a partner who is generous with their money and sees the value in giving is someone with a financial love language. This doesn't have to come from gifts.
情感类的爱的语言会引起许多人的共鸣，他们觉得即使在最艰难的时期，他们也能与伴侣建立联系并得到支持。在最糟糕和最好的时刻都在场的伴侣，会被拥有情感类爱的语言的人高度重视。财务。这是与查普曼最初的爱的语言截然不同的第一个。它经过了调整，因为，你知道的，我们现在看到的这种收入转移、劳动转移。所以一个当伴侣对他们的金钱慷慨并看到给予的价值时感到被爱的人，就是拥有财务类爱的语言的人。这不一定非得来自礼物。
It might be that you pay for dinner. It might be that you pay more of the bills. The way these people feel valued and appreciated will mostly be through gifts or resources. And just a reminder, they don't have to be expensive or lavish. They just have to be well-meaning. Here's another new one, intellectual. And I really like this love language. I think that a lot of us can relate to it.
可能是你付了晚餐钱。可能是你支付了更多的账单。这些人感到被重视和赞赏的方式主要通过礼物或资源。只是提醒一下，它们不一定非得昂贵或奢华。它们只需要是充满善意的。这里还有另一个新的，智力。我真的很喜欢这种爱的语言。我认为我们中的许多人都能与之产生共鸣。
And it was quite surprising to me that Chapman didn't include in his initial list. So people with the intellectual love language, they like to connect through the mind. Oh my God, what's that sexuality type where you look for in love with someone's ideas in their mind? I can't remember. Message me if you remember, or I'll Google it.
而且让我非常惊讶的是，查普曼没有把它列入他最初的清单中。所以拥有智力类爱的语言的人，他们喜欢通过心灵来连接。哦天哪，那种性取向是什么来着，你寻找并爱上某人的想法和他们的心？我想不起来了。如果你记得的话给我发信息，或者我会去谷歌一下。
We can find out together. But people with intellectual love language, they feel loved when their partner values their intelligence, when your partner wants to have engaging conversations with you, when they respect your opinion and they take part in kind of thoughtful discussions of important issues. It's the person who feels loved when their partner is willing to have a debate and disagree with them for the sake of, you know, an intellectual conversation. Physical, we've already talked about this, it's physical touch, it's feeling adored and validated through physical affection.
我们可以一起找出来。但是拥有智力类爱的语言的人，当他们的伴侣珍视他们的智力时，当你的伴侣想与你进行引人入胜的对话时，当他们尊重你的意见并参与对重要议题的深思熟虑的讨论时，他们会感到被爱。这就是那种当伴侣愿意为了一场智力对话而进行辩论和与他们意见不合时会感到被爱的人。身体，我们已经讨论过了，它是身体接触，是通过身体上的爱意来感受被宠爱和被认可。
It's the same as Chapman's one. And then the final and the seventh love language in this adapted kind of model is, is practical. People with the practical love language feel the most loved when their partners chip in with their everyday duties and responsibilities. They feel cared for when their loved ones do the chores and offer to help. We can see that there are, you know, a lot of these are kind of similar to Chapman's original theory, but it's that addition of these extra love languages, intellectual and financial in particular, that I think encompasses more people who may not previously have operated or fit into the traditional framework. By using a more updated diverse sample,
这和查普曼的是一样的。然后在这个改编的模式中的最后也是第七种爱的语言是，务实。拥有务实类爱的语言的人，当他们的伴侣分担日常职责和责任时，会感到最被爱。当他们爱的人做家务并主动提供帮助时，他们会感到被关心。我们可以看到，其中有许多与查普曼最初的理论有点相似，但正是增加了这些额外的爱的语言，特别是智力和财务，我认为它包容了更多以前可能没有运作或不适合传统框架的人。通过使用更新的、更多样化的样本，
this woman, she was able to create a new system or tool that I think is more applicable to modern day settings and modern day relationships. And since the original five love languages were created, relationships have evolved from, you know, what used to be a more, a mostly practical partnership based on efficient division of labor and raising children, to a more spiritual and personal connection that we have higher expectations for. We don't just want to come home to someone who will bring home a paycheck or help us with chores. We want this person to help us kind of achieve our best selves. And there are also more accepted types of relationships now, like open relationships or polyamory, in which aspects like financial and intellectual love
这位女性，她创造了一个更适用于现代环境和现代关系的全新系统或工具。自从最初的五种爱的语言被创造以来，关系已经演变了，你知道的，从过去那种主要基于高效分工和抚养孩子的实用伴侣关系，演变为一种我们对其抱有更高期望的精神和个人连接。我们不仅仅想回到家看到一个带回工资或帮我们做家务的人。我们希望这个人能帮助我们达到最好的自己。现在也有更多被接受的关系类型，比如开放式关系或多边恋，在这些关系中，财务和智力上的爱等方面的中心地位可能更高。
might be more central. You know, yeah, I don't really know how to explain this, but it kind of made sense to me, especially that financial and those financial and intellectual components, you might be able to get words of affirmation and physical touch from someone else, but the person waiting for you at home might be the person you really relate to intellectually and who you have kind of a financial promise to, and that is love. That is a form of love. I think in general it's also important to note that you shouldn't just use love languages as kind of a universal solve to like remedy issues. It's clear that we do need more of a skill set than those, you know, than just five ways, five tools, maybe even seven to face the problems that may exist
你知道，是的，我其实不知道该怎么解释这一点，但这对我来说确实说得通，特别是财务和那些财务以及智力成分，你或许能从别人那里得到肯定的话语和身体接触，但真正在家里等你的人，可能是那个你在智力上真正有共鸣、并且对你有某种财务承诺的人，那就是爱。那是爱的一种形式。我认为总的来说，同样重要的是要注意，你不应该仅仅把爱的语言当作解决问题的通用方法。很明显，我们需要比那些东西更多的技能组合，不仅仅是五种方式、五种工具，甚至可能是七种工具，来面对可能存在于我们关系表面之下的问题。
below the surface of our relationship. You know, maybe going to therapy, working on yourself, fixing your own problems, that's also a form of love that doesn't really fit into any of the ones that we've talked about. When we use a quiz on the internet to tell us something definitive about ourselves, it's not always going to be 100% accurate. I don't need to tell you that. And I don't think it should be taken entirely literally as well. And that's kind of Chapman's main's point. In doing so, you kind of detract from his true intentions. And his intention was to create a tool, an informational tool to help partners communicate and understand each other better rather than kind of narrow the ways in which they show that they care.
你知道，也许去看心理医生，自我提升，解决你自己的问题，这也是一种爱，但它并不真正符合我们谈论过的任何一种。当我们在互联网上使用测验来告诉我们关于自己的某个确定结论时，它并不总是百分之百准确的。这不用我多说。而且我认为也不应该完全照字面意思去理解。这也是查普曼的主要观点。这样做的话，你其实是在贬低他的真正意图。他的初衷是创建一个工具，一个旨在帮助伴侣更好地沟通和相互理解的信息工具，而不是缩小他们表达关心的方式。
That's kind of the end of what we have today. A shorter episode, but short and sweet. And it was really interesting looking into this. I found it, you know, quite insightful, especially now, you know, that I'm not dating anyone or anything like that. I was doing the love language quiz and I realized that, like, since the last time I did it, which was when I was last in a relationship, it's changed so much.
这就是我们今天的全部内容。一集较短的节目，但短小精悍。研究这个真的很有趣。我发现它，你知道的，相当有启发性，尤其是现在，你知道的，我没有在约会或者诸如此类的事情。我当时在做爱的语言测验，我意识到，自从我上次做这个测验——也就是我上次谈恋爱的时候——它已经发生了很大的变化。
Like I realize I think my love languages had kind of adapted to the other person. And now that I'm able to refocus on myself, I kind of realized that some of the things that they were giving to me perhaps weren't actually what I wanted. So it's interesting to do that now versus when I'm in a relationship. And if you haven't done it, you should do it. If you're not dating someone, you should still do it. It's like I said, great for relating to your family, great for relating to your friends as well. Like I know for me personally, I love giving my friend's gifts, but I feel weird when they give them to me. And I would much rather, you know, quality time or like a frequent message or something like that than an act of service or something.
就像我意识到，我的爱的语言似乎已经适应了另一个人。现在我能够重新聚焦于自己，我某种程度上意识到他们过去给予我的一些东西可能并不是我真正想要的。所以在恋爱时做这个和现在做这个，感觉很有趣。如果你还没做过，你应该试试。如果你现在没有在约会，你也应该试试。就像我说的，这对于处理家庭关系很棒，对于处理朋友关系也很棒。比如我知道就我个人而言，我喜欢送朋友礼物，但当他们送我礼物时我会觉得怪怪的。比起效劳或类似的事情，我其实更愿意要，你知道的，高质量的陪伴或者经常发消息之类的。
And it's good to kind of understand that about your friendships and your family. Those relationships are also important. It's not just your romantic partner that should be the most prominent. But thank you again for listening. I hope you enjoyed this episode. I'm going to do my basic spiel now. You know, saying all the things I usually say, blah, blah, blah. If you'd like to review this podcast on Apple Podcasts on Spotify, I would greatly appreciate it.
理解你和朋友以及家人的这种关系是很好的。这些关系同样重要。不应该只有你的浪漫伴侣才是最突出的。但再次感谢你们的收听。希望你们喜欢这一集。我现在要开始我的常规碎碎念了。你知道的，说那些我经常说的话，巴拉巴拉。如果你想在 Apple Podcasts 或 Spotify 上给这个播客写个评价，我会非常感激的。
No, in all seriousness, it really does help the podcast grow. And it's just me doing this. It takes a while to write these episodes. It only takes like four hours to make one. And it's all kind of worth it when I get a nice review or something like that. So if you are getting something out of this, I would really appreciate it. and make sure to follow. I always say us, but it is just me, on Instagram,
不，说真的，这确实对播客的发展很有帮助。而且这全是我一个人在做。写这些节目需要花点时间。制作一集只需要大约四个小时。当我收到一个好评或者类似的东西时，这一切都是值得的。所以如果你从这里有所收获，我会非常感激。还有记得关注。我总是说我们，但其实只有我一个人，在 Instagram 上，
on Facebook, although I don't really use it, but if you feel the need, and subscribe. There we go. There's my three lists of demands. Thank you. And tune in next week. We're going to talk about situationships. Boy, oh boy, I was in a situation ship for seven months this year and last year,
在 Facebook 上，虽然我不太用它，但如果你觉得有必要的话，还有订阅。好了。这就是我的三个要求清单。谢谢。请收听下周的节目。我们要聊聊暧昧关系。天哪，我今年和去年有七个月都处于暧昧关系中，
and let me tell you that, fucked me up. So I have so much to talk about. I've been researching my little butt off to get some good content into the years of all thou who are listening. So tune in for that and have a lovely, lovely week. Thank you. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean
我告诉你，那把我整崩溃了。所以我有很多话要说。我一直在拼命做研究，以便为所有在听的听众提供一些优质的内容。所以请收听那一期，祝你们度过一个非常非常美好的星期。谢谢。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着，仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
你就必须这样做，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会迎来一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
也就是 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。